s'appelle jean poils se dit anti
fasciste et vous avez forcément vu son
museau si vous habitez partenaires des
affiches à son effigie recouvre celle de
candidats comme eric zemmour et jean luc
mélenchon depuis plusieurs jours il a
même un compte instagram jean poil pour
un président si vous voulez aller voir
car oui j'en poil et candidat à la
présidence et 500 signatures bien sûr
l'histoire ne dit pas mais il reste
encore deux jours en tout cas si les a
pas eues ambiance de campagne au salon
de l'agriculture
marine le pen était en opération
séduction hier avec un arrêt au stand
outre-mer très remarquée des images
d'une candidate joyeuse et populaire
idéal en période électorale
autre postulant à l'elysée autre
registre
au stand sud ouest jean lassalle n'a pu
résister un paquito comme dans les
férias de la région mais sur ce coup le
béarnais semble peser un peu plus lourd
que dans les sondages en parlant avec
lui il m'a dit qu'il avait bu trois
vodkas deux en or en deux avec de
l'orangé une pure ah oui jamais faire de
mélange
quand on commence à l'orangé avec eau
chaude au final
je passe mes journées figurez-vous à
m'occuper de ce qu'on rejette des soins
mais parce qu'ils sont pas vaccinés que
je t'ai jamais on casimir
est alors quasi mais je termine là
dessus excusez moi des plaintes ont été
rejetées en encaissant déduisez pardon
qu'est ce que vous en déduisez ce n'est
pas tout à fait de la même manière qu
finalement vous combattez locaux vides
vous en fait aussi un business de
lentilles coville en fait je ne sais pas
combien des plaintes qui est passé par
nantes ou alors si vous savez pas
taisez-vous
premier parpaing qui faisaient la
douleur
m
ouah
[Musique]
j'ai dit
voilà donc à paris le musée grévin a
choisi de retirer la statue de cire d'un
certain vladimir poutine oui alors c'est
la première fois de l'histoire du musée
qu'un personnage est démontée à cause de
l'actualité mardi encore vladimir
poutine trônait entre les grands de ce
monde mais depuis l'invasion russe sa
vie au musée c'était compliqué le
personnel le retrouver chaque soir
décoiffé adressé victimes de l'assaut
des visiteurs si cette rencontre du 7
février était froide et distante les
échanges téléphoniques du jour entre
emmanuel macron et vladimir poutine
était glaciale et inquiétant une heure
trente de discussions à la demande du
président russe et à l'arrivée une
conclusion pessimiste d' emmanuel macron
quant à l'intensification de la guerre
en ukraine le pire est à venir
et rassurez vous si vous ne comprenez
pas tout au conflit entre la russie et
l'ukraine vous n'êtes pas les seuls oui
c'est louis fieu oui je tiens oui dieu
tout le médoc au kivu taxes
effectivement sa préoccupation du moment
ce sont les ukrainiens la résistance
d'une vieille dame face à la police du
régime
applaudi par les manifestants cet
activiste de 76 ans est arrêté encadré
par deux policiers
les images sont vite devenue virale
symbole d'une partie du peuple russe qui
s'oppose publiquement à la guerre
[Musique]
est une chanson qui s'appelle bonne
journée et une chanson qui s'appelle
mauvaise journée ce sont les deux
chanson coécrite par hold up par orelsan
je crois et la mauvaise journée commence
par un kaka raté et la bonne journée par
un kaka parfaitement exact j'adore cette
chanson si c'est gentil bah ouais ouais
bah je me suis dit ce serait marrant de
faire deux chansons en miroir comme ça
et comme quoi la bonne humeur ou penser
aux miroirs moi je pense au cac à
la coupe de tauron c'est dégueulasse à
des copains et je suivrai m'imaginer la
bête les couilles qui bordent sais
c'est l'horreur je me demande même si
j'aurais préféré être éliminé que de
manger ça c'est très très difficile
ainsi mon grand-père telle odeur de gaz
moment idéal pour pleurer ça serait
entre 19h et 22h ça tombe bien c'est le
créneau des créneaux horaires ou le nom
n'est plus susceptible de lâcher prise
ben non mais faut pas rigoler entre 19
et 20 août 2006 qui perd autant et
balaban où on préfère pleurer ah ok une
bonne journée ça se tient ça tient à pas
grand chantier rien non pas un kaka
parfait de feuilles de papier toilette
pas besoin d'essayer un c'est nickel
c'est vraiment vraiment dégueulasse se
mord dedans ça pue ça c'est le goût inné
ory faire garder trop les détails aux
victimes - nantes aurait dû manger tu
regardes pas j'aurais dû j'aurai des
jeux j'aurais dû ouais j'aurais dû la
manger plus vite ce but là vraiment tout
de suite s'est terminée ce possède finir
cette cool en 1080i tourne sur elle même
et en 365 jours la terre qui tourne sur
elle même tournoi est aussi sans colorer
le soleil la journée banos aller on a
des métiers de la nuit à moitié de
journée puisqu'elle tourne autour du
cou pour tourner autour du soleil jamais
ça ne m'a nullement ah bon vous n'avez
jamais entendu cette théorie à terre
elle tourne sur elle même et va pas se
déplacer des coûts savoir les
tremblements de terre quand même je sais
pas c'est plus l'homme qui nous a
accueillis qui arrive c'est mr gros
paquet monsieur en slip comme ça
quinze mecs tu comprend très vite que tu
va le suivre et que ça va pas ça on va
pas rigoler
[Musique]
ces supposés de quoi me fathi ben c'est
censé être la lune ok fiel
[Rires]
je sais pas si on a la même lu non mais
moi c'est pas ça que je vois
deux derrière je veux une image aller
croyable je voyais le guen sleeps
se contorsionner pour aller reprendre
lucas contorsionner lucas michel gros
paquet m et c'est là que la cote de la
torture comme ans
abonde en 365 jours ça fait une année
nice arrive en une année
j'invite toute la ligne et au moins
quelque chose
c'est vrai c'est vrai on a envie d'être
à l'écouté des brenets je viens la vie
est une petite fille aux abonnés après
la pub mais bien sûr
écouter un peu de réconfort c'est tout
chaud tout ça c'est trop mignon c'est
trop cute 1 j'ai entendu une fois qu'il
avait amené une personne d'une chambre
funéraire et qui s'est réveillée dans la
housse on l'a entendu après on a vu ça à
la télé la télé il faut pas toujours
écouter tout ce qu'il raconte jean
pierre pernaut laisse derrière lui toute
une génération
lui qui a assuré pourtant que la télé
n'avait jamais été un objectif vous
embrasse du fond du coeur merci je vous
aime je vous oublierai jamais
voilà ce qu'on pouvait dire ce matin sur
jean pierre foucault